CBS News has learned the alleged Golden
State killer will be charged this
morning for what investigators believe
was his very first murder
Joseph D'Angelo is accused of shooting
Claude Snelling in Visalia California in
1975 in interviews you'll see only on
CBS this morning we spoke to Snelling
'he's daughter who was held at gunpoint
the night of her father's murder and the
district attorney and police chief who
will announce today's new charges
DeMarco Morgan shows us why this check
this case is challenging for prosecutors
to mark good morning good morning guys a
fascinating yet disturbing story police
believe the Golden State killer began
his crime spree in the small farming
town of Visalia that's where detectives
say it's criminal behavior escalated
from sadistic burglar to notorious
serial killer in my heart I believe he's
the one and that my father was his first
victim Elizabeth Hobbs father Claude
Snelling gave up his life to save her
from being abducted by the so called
Visalia ranch hacker in September 1975
she says a masked gunman broke into her
bedroom in the middle of the night
threatened her and then dragged her out
to their carport that's when I heard my
dad yell and the man with a ski mask
pushed me to the ground turned shot my
dad twice as he was coming through the
back door the killer fled snelling died
on the way to the hospital
help was 17 years old at the time he's
always been my hero I would not be here
today I'm sure of it
if it hadn't been for him crime started
here in Visalia Tulare County District
Attorney Tim Ward believes snelling was
the first victim murdered by Joseph
D'Angelo the suspected Golden State
killer we're filing first-degree murder
charges against mr. diangelo along with
an allegation that he used a firearm in
the commission of that murder during the
1970s and 80s D'Angelo allegedly
committed at least 12 other murders and
more than 50 rapes in ten California
counties DNA evidence led to his arrest
in April while D'Angelo is not directly
linked to Snelling to murder by DNA
police chief Jason Salazar says he can
prove D'Angelo is also the vise Celje
ransack ur
we have been able to locate victims and
witnesses that were able to identify mr.
D'Angelo as the suspect back in
that time those crimes were ultimately
tied to the murder of Claude snowing by
a firearm that was taken from one of the
ransacking burglaries at the time of
Snelling x' murder
D'Angelo worked as a police officer
about 12 miles away in the town of
Exeter he is also suspected at about 100
burglaries and attempted sex assaults in
Visalia the only crime that we can
attribute to mr. D'Angelo that has not
passed the statute of limitations is the
murder of mr. Snowie
D'Angelo has not yet entered a plea in
its criminal cases I'm just very happy
that he's caught he's a very evil person
the Visalia wrens hacker was nearly
captured three months after snelling
murder he managed to escape after fired
a gun at a detective who tried to arrest
him and shortly after that investigators
believe he moved to the Sacramento area
beginning a new crime wave as the east
area rapist just when you thought the
story couldn't get any worse we have
this now the linkages through the years
between these killings
my father certainly is a hero that's the
way she feels about it very whole yeah
DeMarco thank you very much